rush
hour what's up guys I got a very
exciting person next to me you want you
know about the movie Braveheart I got
the brave heart next to me right here
not worried about getting cancelled not
worried about getting shut down he's
speaking on the side of Truth guess who
what's up J sh here how you doing
excited to have him on we have him on
the D show coming up soon look out for
that Sal he told us when the soldiers
come they wake everybody up and her them
into a kitchen for hours while soldiers
sleep in their bedroom I think a lot of
Americans don't know this is like the
Norm Norm over there and they'll even
kick people out of their homes for good
it's not it's not Jews it's Israeli
government people need to be very clear
about that it's like you know people are
trying to blame Muslims for 911 that's
completely wrong they need to do the
same with this you can't blame all Jews
for what the zionists are doing over
there yeah I know it's so sad you know
I'm on some of those telegram channels
and gets the point where I can't watch
too many of them because it's just sad
you know these kids or parents losing
their children just video after video
just you see the you see the real
suffering going on over there